man hat das gefühl dass diese stadt sich
wirklich vorbereitet auf gewisse unruhen
und man will eben nicht draußen sein und
da irgendwo in die quere kommen und wir
gucken jetzt einmal auf die andere seite
ich stehe nämlich hier bei einer bank
wir sind gerade von einer anderen bank
hierher gewechselt denn ich habe hier
mit einem handwerker team gesprochen die
jetzt lässt minute aufträge bekommen
haben um hier noch eben holzschutz
anzubringen an die fassaden
denn wenn man auch hier durch das
zentrum läuft im grunde genommen sind
fast alle gebäude schon mit diesem holz
schutz versehen und da gibt es jetzt
noch ein paar letzte die sich jetzt
ebenso spontan kurzfristig überlegt
haben und jetzt wird hier noch gewerkelt
gebohrt ausgemessen und gehämmert hinter
mir und wir sprechen jetzt mal mit dem
chef dieser truppe warum er noch diese
späten aufträge bekommen hat und was
diese worauf diese stadt sich
vorbereitet er hat sehr viel zu tun
deswegen wollten wir nicht zu lange
aufhalten aber jetzt hatte sich ein paar
minuten genommen michael shanks
vorherigen time for a sign new york will
sie hier soll fans haben sehen was nun
ganz beschäftigt sind und das zentrum
der stadt ist schon nagelt worden
bereitet sich die stadt auf das
schlimmste vor ja das sieht so aus wir
sind alle ein bisschen nervös in den
letzten tagen war das schon so und sie
sehen hier dass wir im erdgeschoss alles
verdammen verriegeln und jetzt machen
wir das noch dort drüben und warum
glauben sie dass sie das hier noch in
letzter minute machen sie sehen dass sie
hier noch tätig lange sie diese nacht
warum wurde das jetzt noch am letzten
tag entschieden
sie wollten alle noch aufhalten hier und
jetzt haben wir eben in letzter minute
noch die aufgabe alles zu verriegeln
damit dahin
und was glauben sie wo sich die menschen
hier waren
der moment kommen wir hier unruhen
vielleicht aufkommen wenn vielleicht
schon gewinnt hier in washington
ja ich glaube es könnte ein bisschen
chaotisch werden wenn und aber ich bin
nicht in der politik ich kann das ich
sagen ich bin kein politiker ich weiß
dass nicht genau aber ich glaube viel
hat damit zu tun wer diese wahl
letztendlich gewinnt und hoffentlich
haben wir dann auch irgendwann einen
impfstoff gegen c
und wie lange wird es dauern so ein
gebäude zu sichern
einige sind leichter zu sichern anderer
sind ein bisschen schwieriger zu sichern
wir dürfen hier nicht dieselben
maßnahmen machen wie in anderen
bereichen das heißt es dauert etwas
länger
wir waren wenn sie jetzt hier noch heute
noch tätig sein hoffentlich drei stunden
und dann haben wir noch ein paar andere
standorte glück dabei und den dank dass
sie ein paar minuten für uns hatten
also ja die jungs werden hier noch ein
paar stunden beschäftigt sein um auch
diese band dann zu schützen vor
möglichen ausschreitungen während vorhin
gesprochen er meinte natürlich
washington dc ist eine tiefblaue stadt
und die black lifes männerbewegung ist
hier sehr stark vertreten
deswegen werden natürlich
ausschreitungen vor allem dann erwartet
wenn es möglicherweise nach einem trump
sieg aussieht mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bild schaut euch
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren